I built the first versions it was my my
original project
on the back you've got three three
engines in the back here and then you've
got the fuel that sits above the engines
and then on your arms
you've got this thrust
so it is quite common for people's first
reaction upon seeing this to connect it
with a movie like The Iron Man character
it is not why I started building this
we're actually here training some Allied
European Special Forces to fly this
equipment this is their fourth week of
training and they're all flying
brilliantly and we wanted to bring them
to an interesting location to complete
that training
for the Red Cross or the no no no